I'm scared
you don't think I was afriad the first time I went out into the field
I believe you keep fighting, so suit up
Roulette.  We have got to stop meeting like this
If you go looking for trouble, you always find it
you're bleeding
hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so this is Kevin
Smith Supergirl episode.
It's based on his movie Superman lives, it's
the insane.
Ben Affleck Superman movie the turned into
the even crazier Nicolas Cage Tim Burton Superman
movie so I'll explain all that it is fantastically
weird there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway that's going on to all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video be sure to click that
bell to enable alerts so you don't miss anything.
So what's going on here.
This is Supergirl episode nine, it's Kevin
Smith's episode the title Supergirl lives
is a reference to the unproduced movie that
he wrote the screenplay for called Superman
lives, which I'll explain the second because
it is the craziest Superman story that you've
ever heard of it is ridiculous, which makes
me think that they're going to be borrowing
some concepts from that the not can be doing
Superman lives, but the gonna be doing some
stuff from that Kevin Smith said it's the
biggest episode of TV that he's ever directed
in terms of comic book deep cuts characters
that he's a love so like for instance the
eradicate or was a big part of his Superman
live scripts I'm wondering if there can introduce
the eradicate or.
On Supergirl, it also looks like she passes
through a gateway to a planet with a red son,
that's also part of the story of Superman
lives the evil duo of Lex Luther and Brainiac
turn our yellow son red to take away Superman's
power, so he's powerless for a lot of the
folks you can start to see why they didn't
produce the Superman lives movie but all explained
the plot of that in greater detail in the
second but it looks like was happening here
is just Supergirl is losing her powers because
of the red son.
You also have this alien ship these aliens
were teased at the end of the Supergirl crossover
episode during the big four night crossover
my Lords recent well.
So there is no sinus kryptonian pot the ion
trail is dissipated I would not know where
to look and how much space we must is or how
many sons we they sound like they might be
the dominators from this universe but they
were all wearing helmets.
So you couldn't really tell they were looking
for special nebula like a special area of
space that brought Manel to earth so that
place might be tied to this gateway here,
but the dominators are coming back.
Whether or not these aliens are them the dominators
that we saw during the four night crossover
will be coming back to Supergirl in the back
half of the season, but because it Supergirl
she's in a different universe.
They might be the dominators from her universe
not from the universe and Earth one.
So not technically the same dominators even
though it's the same race of beings just from
a different universe.
Roulette is back, it seems like she has some
mysterious connection to these aliens in the
ship.
So will learn about that, during the back
Of the season.
It seems like roulette's going to be a larger
character over the back Which is cool Deacon
Lockman's great actors, she was really good
on the 100 show she's really good on dollhouse.
So Superman lives.
Let's talk about this monstrosity.
This was the Ben Affleck Superman movie that
turned into the Tim Burton Nicolas Cage Superman
movie.
It was several different versions of its I'll
try to explain everything Kevin Smith was
heavily involved at the Scripps stage he kind
of remembers it fondly.
Now, in retrospect, but this is like many
many years later, it was around 1996, 1997
when they were in production.
This is a long time ago.
So you have to imagine the younger version
of Kevin Smith, just sign when he was asked
to make all these compromises in the script.
So the important figures here Kevin Smith
was the person that was working on the screenplay,
he pitched it to Jon peters who was the producer
the director was going to be Tim Burton so
he I guess you could think of it is Tim Burton's
version of Superman the really most of the
stuff we know about this isn't talking to
Kevin Smith because he wrote the screenplay,
so listen to some of these beats that the
producers wanted Kevin Smith to write into
the screenplay, Smith explained that he was
a hired gun and as such he had to do what
ever they asked for.
So even if they asked for ridiculous stuff
which they definitely did which I'll explain
a second he's had to write in the screenplay,
no matter how crazy he thought it was.
So this kind of changed over time.
But at the start what they asked for was Superman
wearing all black suit.
So people like okay that doesn't sound so
bad Superman in the black suit just like the
comics.
They also did not want him to fly now can
you imagine a Superman can't fly already you're
getting like a little less excited you like
okay you don't maybe he'll be like Golden
age Superman leaping tall buildings in a single
bound, but then Kevin Smith came back and
was like no no no he'll fly and he'll just
create sonic booms.
Every time he does which they actually been
using in the more recent movie, so that such
a pretty cool idea.
So we have Superman flying again.
But then the producers came back and said
okay for the big climactic fight we want Superman
to fight a giant spider.
So naturally, Kevin Smith is like that's the
dumbest idea ever and then later in onto the
film fell apart.
Side note Jon peters also produced that wild
wild West video.
Guess what the big villain turned into at
the end of that movie a giant spider.
So this producer the Kevin Smith was forced
to work with those big deal these crazy demands
which is obsessed with giant spiders for some
reason, but the list goes on.
So Kevin Smith you know being a relatively
young person in Hollywood, which is forced
to do with the producers wanted.
So he started writing the script.
But then the producers came back and said
there's not enough action in the film we want
more fight scenes.
So because Brainiac was going to be one of
the villains of the film they said we want
Brainiac to fight a polar bear up at the Fortress
of solitude.
So you know Kevin Smith is just kinda shaking
his head quietly this whole time like no.
This is terrible terrible idea, and then because
around that time Star Wars was getting its
20th anniversary re-released in theaters if
you remember the special editions that's basically
what it was they re-release the Star Wars
movies in theaters so Lucasfilm had all this
merchandising going on so toy sales were making
producers a lot of money, so the producers
of Superman lives were saying okay we want
more things in the movie that we can turn
into toys, so that we can make more money,
so they asked Kevin Smith to write a dog a
space dog into the movie that Brainiac would
give to Lex Luther just for merchandising
reason so that we can make a toy from it.
Not because Brainiac giving Lex Luther a space
dog made sense for the story.
So then they asked Kevin Smith to also write
in an assistant for Brainiac the like we want
him to have a robot assistant name L Ron yes
with that's code for L Ron Hubbard voiced
by Hooper X from chasing Amy it was going
to be like this gay robot assistant.
That's what the producers call that they said
that we want Brainiac to have a gay robot
assistant.
Just like C3 PO this was happening around
the Star Wars special edition rereleases.
So there was a lot of Star Wars being inserted
into movies all over the place.
But I do laugh at the idea like it's so funny
just the idea of Hooper X voicing a robot
assistant to Brainiac in a Superman movie
that would be the most hilarious disaster
ever so then Kevin Smith went away.
Wrote a bunch of the movie came back in in
the big part of the story of the Superman
lives part of it came from the idea that Brainiac
sent doomsday to kill Superman he blocked
out the sun.
So Superman was powerless and then just like
in the comics you know the return of Superman
Superman is resurrected by the eradicate or
and is able to eventually defeat Brainiac
and Lex Luther.
So around that time Kevin Smith's choice for
Clark Kent Superman was Ben Affleck.
So there was appeared of time in the late
90s when Ben Affleck would have been Superman
which is no pretty hilarious because he's
Batman now I think it worked out for the better
because when Tim Burton got involved with
the movie that's when it became the Nicolas
Cage monstrosity they changed a bunch of Canon
like it almost became unrecognizable as a
Superman comic book story so they rewrote
Kevin Smith's version of the story and that's
when it turned into like something that was
really crazy.
So like Kevin Smith wrote a version of the
movie that was pretty good but had a lot of
ridiculous things that the producers asked
him to put in, but it was still pretty recognizable
as like a death and return of Superman from
the comic story then when Tim Burton got involved
it got really crazy.
So like for instance Superman absorbs solar
radiation from the yellow sun.
That's what gives him his power in heels them
during the return of Superman.
It also brings him back to life.
So to speak.
I mean, he didn't really die.
He was just very close to death.
So in the new crazy Tim Burton version of
the movie he's brought back to life by the
power of K a natural force representing the
spirit of krypton the new rider who was rewriting
Kevin Smith's version also combined Lex Luther
and Brainiac into a single entity called Lexi
act.
So it just sounds like the most ridiculous
thing ever.
What started out as a really good idea and
Kevin Smith said as Superman lives was kind
of perverted by Hollywood and then later totally
took it up the butt as people who didn't care
about the comics, just completely try to change
it.
It turned in the like this 11 year process.
It had nothing to do with George Romero's
Justice league that's a completely separate
project.
This was just a Superman movie.
So thank God that it fell apart.
You know Kevin Smith is just like okay you
know it was a fun project to work on, but
at the time.
I'm sure it was just a living nightmare for
him, but now you know he's been directing
episodes of the flash so when Supergirl came
to Vancouver.
He was like yeah I would be awesome to do
in episode a Supergirl so the producer of
Supergirl is the same producer of the flash
and he revealed the Kevin Smith episode would
be title Supergirl lives in Kevin Smith just
started crying.
He was like aww thank you so much.
This is so wonderful.
So like I said we don't know exactly what
the plot of his Supergirl lives episode, is
but it sounds like they're borrowing some
beats and some concepts from his Superman
lives screenplay may be like the eradicate
or like he said deep cuts from the comics
so be like that's a great tip for eradicate
or and blocking out the sun.
Although looks like red sun here she was still
looser powers, but that also means that Brainiac
might make an appearance.
So if you have a broad idea of what Superman
lives was what do you think the gonna do for
this Supergirl lives episode and just re-watching
this trailer footage I wish they cut all the
trailers like this that we are junk cutting
the creepy atmospheric music.
I'm afraid I feel like this is a much better
version of the Supergirl trailer than you
would normally see like I really love it when
Supergirl does Jon Carpenter type stuff, so
I'm probably not can it do a video for this
episode but I will do Supergirl videos in
the future if they do like big comic book
concepts, but speaking of Superman I did say
I was gonna do a Superman versus doomsday
video just because I've literally done like
two Superman videos in a row I'm in a wait
a day and do it on Wednesday tomorrow will
be some new Marvel just because of the doing
a whole bunch a DC lately, so let me know
if is any special Superman bonus videos you
guys want me to do during the break.
So they also just posted a new arrow trailer
I'll do a video for that it confirms which
version of Laurel is going to be coming on
the show.
So it's a pretty big deal.
So I'll post that in the morning also say
congratulations to the new flash ring giveaway
winner sacred shakes just private message
me on the back and my channel so I can get
your contact details.
There is a new round that started in this
video just remind everyone when I post that
arrow video while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my black Adam
versus Superman PC movie video and you can
click here for the trailer for the flash thank
you so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight!